well you know every once in a while it
does happen that a guest cancels on us
at the last second and we had two
choices today Choice number one would
have been cancel the show throw the show
in the toilet flush it 10 to 15 times no
show the other option is let's open the
phone lines very briefly and hear from
just a few people in our audience and
you know I like people in the audience
more or less as much as I like our
guests so it seems like a very good uh
alternative let's do this via Discord
which you can find at davidpackman.com
Discord and I don't even want to wait
anymore let's just go right in and start
with Mike from Southeastern Pennsylvania
Mike we've got the Oz fetterman debate
tonight I know you'll be watching
oh yes I will yeah what are you
expecting
I think they're gonna probably pick on
Letterman for his health conditions yeah
I think so uh but that's my question to
you what was on your mind Mike
uh I was wondering why don't they pass
the stamp tax to raise revenue that's
non-detectable
like for like corporate Jets or Yachts
or something like yeah sorry did you say
a stamp tax yeah pass the stamp tax for
various luxury or excise items yeah so
stamp taxes are basically uh sometimes
they're called duties that's d-u-t-y
they are taxes on specific types of
property purchases I mean don't there
already are a bunch right like isn't
there like a yacht tax and a pro or is
that state I guess I don't know enough
about it to know what's currently in
place
oh yeah I just noticed the inflation is
really high for um
luxury items so to clamp that down why
not just pass more Duty taxes well but I
don't know that the big concern is that
luxury goods that a tiny portion of
people can afford are expensive my
instinct was more as a way to increase
government revenue
it would be something to look at right
or why would you be looking to do it
yeah to increase resonance with State
the post office it would create like a
substant collection Market that people
would probably collect the stamps
oh boy I think we have some confusion
generally speaking when people talk
about a stamp tax it's not about
collectible stamps it's a tax on a
particular type of item
oh I know but I say just create create
stamps or create um non-fungible tokens
something that people can trade with
just oh you're literally saying make
stamps that people can collect oh yeah
definitely oh my goodness Mike I don't
know if you're serious but I appreciate
the call thank you all right very good
was that was that a joke I can't even
tell